Hi, welcome back. In this session, I'd
like to follow up on what I started
talking about in the last session. If
you remember in the last session, we
talked about insiders, looking at
insiders buying and insiders selling and
whether they make money from that buying
and selling and the answer is kind of
mixed. It looks like they do on average
and whether you can make money using
information and insider trading. And
there the EV evidence is much more
murky. In this session, I'd like to
focus on another group of people that we
think of close to insiders, equity
research analysts, and look at what they
might bring to the table and whether you
and I as investors might benefit from
what they bring to the table. So, let's
start by looking at what equity research
analysts do. Before I embark on this
though, it's worth remembering that
equity research analysts fall into two
camps. There are byside analysts who
work for the the mutual funds, you know,
fund managers, the Fidarities, the State
Streets of the world who do research for
their own portfolio managers. We almost
never hear about those by side analysts.
But you also have sellside analysts who
work for the investment banks and they
have high profiles. You see them on on
in in the financial press or on CNBC.
My focus is going to be on sellside
equity research analysts because they're
they're the only ones who share what
they do with the public. So what is the
case that you can make that sellside
equity research analysts have an
advantage over the rest of us? First you
can argue that they have access to
public information just like the rest of
us but they also have access to the
managers of the firm. Now, of course,
there are restrictions on what managers
can share to them, but that access might
give them at least implicit information
about what's coming to the firm. Because
equity research analysts are sector
focused, they follow 15 or 20 companies.
You could also argue that they know a
great deal more about a sector than you
and I do because they spend their entire
lives following, you know, big box, you
know, retailers or following
semiconductor chip companies that
they're sector specialists.
They do have the data that the rest of
us do, but they probably have better
data access because their employers can
pay the thousands of dollars to get a C
fact or capital IQ or any other data to
them and perhaps more expensive tools.
They can use this as the data. So maybe
they can make use that to make better
forecasts of earnings and as we will see
that's a big part of what sellside
equity research analysts do and revising
those earnings. And finally, sellside
equity research analysts make buy or
sell recommendations on companies. They
pass these recommendation to their
clients and their clients can act on
them. And to the extent that their
clients listen to these analysts and act
on them, it's entirely possible that
when a sellside analyst makes a buy
recommendation, clients buy based on
that and that can push up the price.
There's a price effect. With sell
recommendations, the opposite happens.
So there's an argument to be made that
sellside equity research analysts do
have advantages and should show up in
what they do. Now before we look at what
equity research analysts do and whether
there's money to be made from looking at
what they do, it's worth also
remembering where these sellside equity
research analysts congregate. What I
have in this graph from 2025 is I've
classified companies based on market cap
for US companies from smallest to
largest. lowest bottom desile at the
smallest companies, the top decal of the
largest companies. You can already see
that the number of analysts is far
greater with the larger companies by 28
analysts on average. Whereas with the
smallest companies, the average is 60.
In fact, only 6 and a half% of the
smallest companies have salesside equity
research analysts tracking them. The
remaining 90 90 96% plus have no analyst
tracking them. Whereas when you look at
the largest market cap companies, close
to 81% of them have equity research
analysts tracking them. So if you look
at who companies followed, three things
that seem to drive it. One is market
cap. Larger companies are more likely to
be followed by equity research analysts
and smaller companies. Second is
institutional holding. The greater the
percent of stock held by institutions,
the more likely it is to be followed by
analysts. And the reason is very simple.
As I said, sellside equity research
analysts do research for clients. They
don't get paid for the research. The
clients have to do business with the
banks that the analysts work at to get
to make money on this research. That's
more likely to happen with institutions
and individuals. So, the larger the
institutional holding in a company, the
greater the likelihood it's going to be
tracked by analysts. And finally,
trading volume matters. More liquid
stocks where there's more trading volume
are more likely to be tracked by
analysts than less liquid stocks. Larger
companies, more institutional holding,
higher trading volume all lead to more
equity research following the company
and much more output from that equity
research. So let's focus a little bit on
what sellside equity research analysts
do. In addition to doing all their
research, one of the key things that you
get out of cell side equity research
analysts is forecasts of earnings per
share often for the next quarter or the
next year and they constantly update
these forecasts. I would wager that a
significant amount of time that sellside
equity research analysts do on research
goes into these earnings forecasts. Now
if you look at those earnings forecast
itself and look at what information they
carry first to the extent that sellside
analysts are getting information from
the firm that is not available to the
rest of the public and I'll have to put
quotes on that information because in
the US at least technically that
shouldn't happen but there's other ways
of conveying information that
information can go into the forecast.
Analysts can also look at macroeconomic
developments. Is the economy getting
stronger or weaker? If it's getting
stronger, maybe your forecast for retail
companies and cyclical companies will
improve. It could also be information
that analysts get by looking at
competitors. When one automobile company
reports better than expected earnings,
you as the equity research analyst might
increase your forecast for other
automobile companies as well.
There can also be private information
about the firm that doesn't come from
the firm itself but that analysts
themselves collect through a variety of
sources. And finally, there is a whole
host of public information out there
that can go into their forecast. The
bottom line is when analysts forecast
earning, they should do much better than
somebody who just uses historical
earnings and makes a forecast of the
next period. In other words, a time
series model. There have been studies
that have looked at how well sellside
equity research analyst earnings
forecast measure up and the results are
actually surprisingly modest.
The good news is on average sellside
analyst forecasts are better than time
series model forecasts. How do we
measure better or worse? You look at the
forecast error. What the forecasts are
relative to actual the if you have
perfect forecasts the forecast error is
zero. Nobody has zero forecast errors
and on average that forecast error is
lower for for analysts than from time
series models. Okay, that's good, right?
But not by much. One study found for
instance that the average forecast error
when you use time series models is about
32%.
And the analyst forecast error is about
28%. That's a surprisingly small drop
off given how much time, money, and
resources we spent forecasting earnings.
In fact, when you look at these time
series models even on a quarterto
quarter basis, you know, time series
models actually outperform analyst
forecast from April through August and
then underperform them from September
through January. Read into it whatever
you want about second quarter, third
quarter where the advantage for analysts
comes from. And much of the forecast
accuracy of analysts comes in the near
term. In other words, one quarter ahead
forecast you have a shot of using
analyst forecast and doing better than
time series. You make that one year
ahead. The improvement drops off and
when you go to the long term that that
becomes and as we'll see almost
impossible to find a forecast error
improvement.
Now if you look at the forecast errors
over time and this is from a fairly old
study it needs updating. You find that
the forecast errors that analysts make
about earnings seem to be a function of
how well the economy is doing. And this
might not surprise you. When the economy
is doing better than expected, that's
that's what industrial production
captures. The forecast error seems to be
negative. In other words, analysts
underestimate earnings. When the economy
is doing worse than expected, analysts
overestimate earnings. Maybe the
macroeconomic component is not finding
its way into the forecast as much as it
should. So let's summarize with
short-term forecast. On average, analyst
forecast errors are smaller than time
series models, but the savings are
modest. And even with one quarter ahead
of forecast, they're a function of the
time you're in, what the economy is
doing. Now, you look at long-term
forecasts, analysts sometimes forecast
fiveyear earnings. And there's a story
there. come back to when you look at
these longerterm forecasts, the results
are much more mixed. Some studies find
no improvement. In fact, one study in a
very early study concluded that analysts
were not great long-term forecasters. A
much later study said there's some
improvement, but it's not that much. But
here's the most telling detail. If you
have a large market cap company tracked
by 35 or 40 or 50 analysts, not all of
them make five year forecasts. In fact,
60 to 70% of analysts skip that step.
They stay with one quarter ahead and one
year ahead. Telling you something about
what they think about their capacity to
forecast longer term growth.
So that's a big component is forecasting
earnings. In the next session, we'll
talk about what happened the actual
earnings come out. But analysts also
revisit their forecast. So they make
their forecast of next quarter earnings
and then they'll revisit it a week or
two weeks, 3 weeks later and they make
revisions those earnings and there is
there seems to be some information in
what kind of revisions you can make.
Let's break it down. Analysts can
revisit an earnings forecast and either
revise it up because they got good news
in those three weeks or revise it down.
When analysts revise earnings up, there
seems to be excess return. Stock prices
tend to go up in the months after
positive revisions.
And when you look at um you know
comparing the most extreme revisions
have the biggest and should come as no
surprise biggest stock price effect. But
here again there's there's some
fuzziness in the findings. Much of the
excess return is concentrate in the
weeks around the revision. Right? In
fact, the one study found that prices
before positive revisions were actually
negative in the week before and positive
in the week after. And that some
analysts have a much bigger impact.
We'll categorize them as leaders because
of the number of people who track them.
And we'll talk later about who goes into
that leader pack have a much greater
impact. So earnings forecasts are out
there. Revisions earnings seem to have
information. But I think there's a
pitfall in using analyst earnings
forecast as your basis for investing.
After all, analyst forecast earnings
rest on the two weakest links in this
process. One is earnings coming out from
companies which are subject to
accounting gaming and analyst forecast
which are biased.
Much of the analyst impact comes from
having clients who will trade bu based
on those based on the earnings
forecasts. And the more influential an
analyst becomes, the greater the client
effect is. In fact, as an aside,
sellside equity research analysts have
their own special club, a club for the
very best of them. It's called an
all-America team of analysts. And you
think the all-America team of analysts
would include the analysts who are best
at forecasting. It's not. It doesn't. It
actually includes the analysts who have
the biggest client base, who have the
biggest influence, have the biggest
megaphone out there. much of what you
can make on on based on an on analyst
forecast is short-term. Even those
revisions I talked about short-term and
the returns we're talking about are not
50 or 100%. They're 1% or 2%. Put
simply, you're not going to get rich of
analyst forecast, but you might get a
little richer. And finally, it does seem
to matter who the analysts are that some
sellside analysts have such a low
profile and so few clients that they
don't affect prices. Maybe the entire
analyst effect comes from that client
effect that they have clients following
their advice.
So that's earnings earnings forecast
their pluses and minuses. There's some
some information there. But analysts
also put out recommendations.
Generally speaking, you can think of
these recommendations falling into three
parts. They're buy recommendations,
there are sell recommendations, and
there are hold recommendations.
But analysts actually go a little
further. you put, you know, they they
they have gradation. Strong buy, weak
buy, hold, weak sell, strong sell. So,
you break these stocks down on these
five groupings in 2025. Here's what the
recommendations look like. Buy
recommendations vastly outnumber sell
recommendations. This has always been
true. People have talked about it.
Doesn't go away. Some of it might come
from the bias in the process. You're a
sellat analyst and you track 15
companies. You need to maintain good
relations with that company. And if you
put a sell recommendation, you might
burn your bridges. That company might
never talk to you. So this process
skewed towards buy versus sell. And
everybody knows that. And the strong
buy, weak buy, strong sell, weak sell
becomes an implicit way an equity
research analyst can ask you to sell. A
lowering of a company from strong buy to
weak buy is actually a sell without
saying the word sell. So these
recommendations are made by companies
and presumably people look at them and
they act on them and if you look at
stock prices around these
recommendations and this is from a study
again that's dated I haven't found an
updated version of the study can talk
about something this is what happens to
stock prices on the day of the
recommendation one month after 3 months
after and six months after so when a
stock is added to a buy there is a jump
on the stock price for about three three
and a half% %. If you track it 1 month
after, it's about 8%, 2 months after,
it's about 7 and a half%. But if you
track it 6 months later, it's back down
to about 2.5%. You're saying, what does
that mean? There's an immediate impact
from the recommendation. It builds on
itself. There's a drift after the
recommendation, but there if you track
it long enough, much of the boost you
get from the recommendation seems to
fade away. When a stock is removed from
a buy,
maybe from a buy to a hold or a strong
buy to a weak buy, the initial effect is
negative. [clears throat] One month
later, it's less negative. 3 months
later, it's slightly more negative, but
6 months later, it's much more negative.
Negative recommendations seem to have
much more staying power. And you see
that even with the added to sell, much
more staying power because 6 months
after the stock is down much more than
it was in the initial day.
But if you look at buys and you know
removed from sales it the effect is is
much fuzzier. There's an initial
positive but by the time you get to 6
months later the overall effect is all
of these we're talking about small
change in the price. There is an effect
that recommendations have that's
consistent with the recommendations buys
the stock price goes up sells stock
price goes down but there there are
questions about how much it goes up and
how how much staying power that has. So
recommendations have an effect but in
many cases that effect fades over time.
There's one more caveat to add about
about equity research analyst
recommendations. Equity research
analysts often work for investment banks
and investment banks often have other
business that they do with the companies
that these sellside equity research
analysts track. This creates a conflict
of interest. Right? So one study
actually looked at recommendations made
by sellside analysts who have no other
investment banking business in this case
underwriting business and sellside
equity research analysts where their
investment banks had banking business
with. And this shouldn't perhaps come as
a surprise, but it turns out that by
recommendations by PE by by analysts who
have other business with a company have
much less staying power. So maybe when
you look at a sellside analyst
recommendation, you also check out
whether the investment bank they work
for has other business with the company
being tracked.
So you decide to go this route of using
analyst recommendations. Can you make
money off of recommendations? In the
near term, the answer seems to be yes,
but only if you jump in before the
recommendation comes out. I'm not sure
how you get that. Maybe there's a select
group of clients that analysts release
these recommendations. If you're in that
select group, but if you wait for the
recommendation to come out, the price
jump has already happened. I'm not sure
there's much money to be made. If you
decide to take this route of looking at
sellside analysts and incorporating what
they do into the process, here's my
suggestion on things you should do.
First, look for the analysts who have
the biggest impact, the most following
because that price impact matters.
Screen out analysts who have conflicts
of interest. You know, we talked about
the conflicts of interest of banking
business.
If you invest based on the
recommendations, go ahead. But remember,
you need to get out at the right time
because some of these the buzz that you
get from the recommendation fades over
time. And also watch your analyst for
those very subtle signals that they
might let out because know we talked
about how they try to tell you to sell
without ever using the word sell. Strong
buy to weak buy. Watch out for those
signals because those signals will have
a price effect as well. So I you know I
can I I don't use analyst
recommendations in my investing but if
you can find a way to incorporate into
your investing philosophy all the more
power to you. In doing all of this
though there are some things to
recognize about [clears throat] the
entire business world the market that we
live in. First is the advantages that
equity research analysts have have over
the rest of us has shrunk dramatically.
Part of it is new rules and insider
information making it more difficult for
companies at least in Europe and the US
to share the data just with analysts.
There might be some emerging markets
where you still can get insider
information as an analyst. Access to
public data has been much more
democratic. I can get the same filings
and data that a Goldman Sachs analyst
can. And that wasn't true 30 years ago.
And the tools that that these analysts
use, you and I can have access to them.
Whether it's Excel or Python, we can
build our own tools that can match up to
them. So the analyst advantages have
shrunk. And it's worth remembering that
analysts don't play the investing game.
Your job as a sellad analyst when you
ask me to buy a stock is you're not
telling me the stock is cheap. You're
just telling me it's cheaper than the
other 15 companies you track. You tell
me to sell it's more expensive. You play
the pricing game, not the investing
game. And I've got to factor that in
when I look at your recommendation. So
when you ask when you put a buy
recommendation on an AI stock, all you
might be saying is this is the least
overpriced AI stock out there, not that
it's an underpriced AI stock. So the
game is evened out. The analyst
recommendations have a lesser impact
today than they did. And people but
people often act on these
recommendations, right? Maybe there's a
different game you can play where you
can assume that these price reactions
are overroought. So when an analyst puts
a buy and the stock jumps 10%, you
assume that that's over that that that
10% is going to fade. You sell short
that stock. Conversely, if the stock
drops 20% because there's a sell
recommendation, you go buy the stock.
You're playing against the analyst here
because you think the clients are being
led down the garden path. I hope you
found this session useful and I thank
you very much for listening.